votre parcours est assez atypique parce
que vous avez étudié à polytechnique
puis après sa défaite votre théâtre -
est ce qui s'est passé au moins moi je
t'ai pas destiné à va faire ça du tout
du tout je n'ai pas d'une famille halimi
culturel je pense que je suis fou ça
peut te consoler je pense la même c'est
pas que pour moi c'est un mystérieux est
attiré par sol goethe attirés par des
certains certaines figures de proue
comme yvon deschamps pour le nommer ou
l'épaule mais bon je dis c'est pas pour
moi et un ami à moi avait vu la ligue
nationale mais ronan sont en ville il a
décidé de donner sens à notre cégep et
puis on s'est mis à faire de l'impro on
aurait pu jouer au baseball on aurait pu
jouer au ballon balai ça a été de
l'impro pis ça moche je me suis réveillé
quelque chose que je soupçonnais pas en
moins mais je vous prie de respecter
matin
est-ce que les clichés sont vraies les
clichés sont vrai parce que de plus en
plus de gens qui sont en guinée mans de
l'union des artistes ayant je dirais que
globalement il ya moins de travail aussi
il ya peut-être plus de support il ya
des séries web sommet dans l'optique de
gagner sa vie dans l'optique de le voir
comme un métier un métier parmi tant
d'autres mais c'est un métier qu'on
prêter à un moment donné de vivre que
dans la précarité s'essoufflait mots
j'en vois du monde et discret qui
travaillent ce n'est pas que le facteur
talent qui détermine seul un facteur
chance qu'on absout non mais moi j'étais
très très chanceux pour trop réfléchir
un fait est le goût d'essayer ça ait
connu nous sommes laissés emporter par
conversation parce que le départ que son
jeu posé c'est quand des premiers films
que j'ai vus de vous c'est louis 19 roi
des ombres ça dérange pas que je
t'appelle louis
non non
ce mois-ci royal royal appelant lui 19
annoncé peut-être le monde ans que l'on
dit aujourd'hui où on est constamment
surveillé oui les caméras partout donc
web et à ce moment là quand on a fait le
film the wild
c'est un peu ça commencé mais cette
époque là ce que sa lettre de la télé
réalité à cause des bons offices de
presque de la science fiction qu'un
certain point
des visionnaires heureusement c'est pas
tout à fait ça pour que des fois on n'en
est pas loin
avoir son quinze minutes de gloire
pendant ces quinze minutes on a
l'impression qu'on existe parce qu'il ya
des témoins de notre existence
c'est exister mais ces personnes ne six
cantons n'existait pas haut mais vivre à
ce point là dans le regard des autres
ça me fascine cela m'interpelle sam je
suis sam
ça me choque jusqu'à un certain point
parce que je fais voyons pourquoi qui a
à me demander si tu sens le débat c'est
5,4 que je me questionne
on faisait beaucoup vu dans la série lol
qui célèbre sa 10e saison
ça a été un gros changement dans votre
carrière
mais moi je garde la tête assez froide
le sud ouest je me méfie du succès
choletais dans le succès qu'on voit la
valeur de quelqu'un parce que l'échec
nous rend humble on veut le partager
notre échec on puis on veut se protéger
on le partager et ça nous amène à une
belle humilité le l'échec
le succès il faut être très fort pour
moi je considère le succès qu'on
reconnaît la force morale psychologique
de quelqu'un passait bien tentant de
penser que le succès des techniques à
tous en tant que comédien producteur
comment on met la main sur un des pièces
de théâtre les plus mythiques au québec
gourou ça prend de la volonté
ça prend aussi beaucoup d'argent ben ça
s'est fait assez simplement légaux de
brouille à 5-6 ans avait évoqué la fin
de leur parcours
pierre conquet le but de la victoire à
la finale de la c3 c3 et droit et puis
ils se sont manifestés à nous c'est sûr
il y avait les auteurs aussi qu'ils
avaient leur mot à dire là dedans
pire bon est ce que c'est une flatterie
qui nous ont dit on dit qu'il y avait
déjà eu il va qui vingtaine d'années en
zèbre
si maintenant on arrête est faible ou
qui pourraient nous remplacer il aurait
dit il faudrait vérifier avec lui mais
il aurait dit il y avait pensé du tour
alors qu'on ne sait même pas vraiment
associés ensemble à ce moment là je sais
pas si c'est vrai je pense qu'une flaque
une forme et
mais tant mieux c'est vrai marten
résident
quel plaisir moeurs bref possible c'est
beaucoup ce monde augmente il a mis deux
patates aussi pour regagner deux
premiers trios